I see this a lot on the internet Abra's  gonna hurt him I have been the one that  has been heartbroken don't oh my god me  but I've never cheated on any of my  boyfriend's and you have never said  anything mean about Kanye this is after  six seven years of constant bullying  from him you don't say that about my  baby I was crying for so long the only  thing that I got from him was Fame I had  to take that out I had to take that  heartbreak on top of it you're not  telling us good I had a full Dark  Twisted Fantasy is not about you right  no one in a great sacred piece of it's a  great part of history and hip-hop and  I'm happy to be a part of it but during  that time was not a great time for me  because I'm famous and I'm broke can't  date anybody else I can't say anything  on the internet because Kanye has such a  voice I was killing myself I would have  done it during those times  [Music]